今天我們來聊聊一個滿有趣的案例，一家丹麥公司 Pandektes，專做法律科技，最近募到 1350 萬歐元，不算小數目。
法律科技？嗯，聽起來很專業。不過現在 AI 不是什麼都能做嗎？他們的「創新點」在哪裡？總不會只是把法律資料餵給 AI 這麼簡單吧？
其實他們出乎意料的地方就在這。一般人想到 AI 應用，都會想著模型要多厲害，但 Pandektes 卻專注在「數據基礎設施」上，尤其針對法律這種高度專業的領域。
數據基礎設施？這要怎麼說？是說他們把法律條文、判例這些資料，整理得很整齊嗎？聽起來好像沒那麼「AI」啊。
對，可以這麼理解。他們把數據前處理和知識圖譜視為 AI 應用的核心競爭力。你看，Alstin Capital 的合夥人 Andreas Schenk 也說了，很少看到像法律研究這樣，這麼多終端用戶想換系統卻換不了的市場。
但光是整理資料，就能募到 1350 萬歐元？這模式能撐多久？會不會哪天其他大公司也把資料整理好了，他們就沒優勢了？
這點其實不容易做到。根據原文，Pandektes 的兩位創辦人 Casper Laursen 和 Søren Brokær，他們從 2022 年就開始搭建這個平台，持續收集、結構化、連接各種法律資訊。
這包含了立法、法院判決、行政裁決，還有其他法律來源，並把它們跟組織自己的數據結合起來。這個過程很複雜，過去甚至導致地方性的供應商幾乎形成壟斷。
所以他們是靠「量」跟「品質」取勝？把大家覺得很難、很瑣碎的事情，用 AI 技術規模化處理？
是的，而且他們不只整理，還保持更新。Laursen 也說，以前要建立一個有力的競爭者幾乎被認為不可能，但現在他們能大規模收集並理解法律資訊，這是以前做不到的。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。Pandektes 目前已經在丹麥、德國和瑞士營運，超過 500 家律師事務所、企業和公共機構都在使用他們的服務。
而且他們過去 12 個月的收入成長了六倍，大約三分之二試用平台的組織，最後都成為付費客戶。這代表他們不只做到了，而且做得還不錯。
這樣說起來，對想導入 AI 但數據雜亂的中小企業來說，這的確是個關鍵洞見：AI 應用成功的背後，其實是深厚的數據結構化工作。
沒錯。如果我是創業者或主管，我就會從這裡學到，別只盯著 AI 模型有多炫，而是先問問自己：「我們的數據夠乾淨嗎？有結構化嗎？」這才是基礎。
嗯，這確實是很務實的建議。很多公司可能砸大錢買了 AI 解決方案，結果因為資料太亂，模型根本跑不出效果。
對一般上班族來說，這概念也能用。比如說，你手邊的工作資料是不是常常散落在不同檔案裡？如果能先花時間把資料整理好、分類清楚，之後要做分析、要寫報告，AI 工具就能發揮更大的作用。
也就是說，把「整理」這件事做到極致，本身就是一種創新，也能創造出巨大的價值。不一定要做出多麼天馬行空的產品，而是把最底層的事情做好。
這是個不錯的啟發。Pandektes 募到 1350 萬歐元，也提醒我們，有時候創新並不是追求表面上的光鮮亮麗，而是專注解決最核心、最難纏的問題。
的確，或許未來 AI 的競爭，最終會回到誰擁有最優質、最結構化的數據。
好像也提醒了我們，那些看似無趣的基礎工作，其實可能蘊藏著巨大的潛力。